Hello大家好我是阿迪
今天要来跟大家分享一个非常万用的手冲冰咖啡的手法
夏天到了大家在家里可能都会想要来一杯冰咖啡
那今天要来跟大家分享一个我觉得非常好用的一个手冲冰咖啡的手法
那这个手法呢我有分享给一些咖啡师的朋友
那大家都还蛮喜欢的
所以想说今天也把这个手法来跟大家分享
那研磨度呢可以选择比你平时手冲还要再细一点点的研磨度
那像今天我用的是Easypresso的K Pro系列
平时的手冲研磨度是8
那这次要冲冰咖啡嘛
所以我们会把研磨度调整到6.5
那你如果是用不同的器材的话
你就可以自己去调整看看
不要调的太细
就比平时手冲再细一点点就可以了
那要准备20克的咖啡
像我們家電動磨豆機是用小飛馬的手沖的話我们通常是用4.5如果是在冲这个手法的话我们就会把它敲全到3.5左右
今天要用的滤杯是西芒滤杯
放上滤汁
冰块呢我们一开始就可以先放在下壶
冰块的量大概是150克左右
咖啡粉倒下去
那這次我們要做的手松冰咖啡呢
是用20克的粉
會煮180克的水
水溫可以設定在92度
第一株悶蒸的水量會給到40克
40克的水我們會悶蒸45秒
45秒
那這時候呢
你就可以去準備一個湯匙
因為等一下第二段的時候我們會用攪拌法我自己在習慣做餅咖啡的時候會選比較偏日曬或是特殊處理法的豆子因為它這樣子的香氣會比較奔放
45秒之後就可以注水
第二注我們要注到120克
也就是說給80克的水
然後倒120
可以稍微往外繞圈
你會發現水會稍微有點淹起來
那這時候拿湯匙快速攪拌
攪拌大概10秒鐘
第三柱 柱到180克
就是給60克的水
讓它有點醃起來
等水全部流完之後
就需要攪拌一下下火
讓你的咖啡液趕快降溫到一個程度
好
它就可以把它倒出來然後把咖啡液倒出來
OK 這樣就可以得到一杯手沖的冰咖啡
那我自己覺得這個手法算是
可以讓咖啡本身的那個香氣
还有它的甜感
快速的被萃取出来
也不会因为过度的萃取而产生苦涩味
那今天就跟大家分享这个
我觉得很好用的手冲冰咖啡
那你如果有一些其他的
手冲冰咖啡的手法的话
也欢迎在底下留言跟我们分享
那大家在家里如果也有试这个
手冲冰咖啡的手法的话
也欢迎在底下跟我分享你喝到的感觉
那今天影片就到这边结束了
我们下期见
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜